If you are struggling to progress your
deadlift and it looks like this, this,
or like this, then you're making the
same mistake as the rest of these
lifters and that's probably why it's
stuck. Now, this mistake isn't just
limited to beginners, either. Check this
out. This lifter here is pulling 285
kilos and
same mistake. So, what's happening here?
Well, all of these deadlifts are more of
a pull than a push. And when we pull
deadlifts, what ends up happening is we
use a lot more of our back than we need
to and we're not using our quads. If we
watch Aaron's deadlift here, there's a
little dip before the pull, but then his
hips shoot right back up and he ends up
pretty much stiff legging it. Now, both
Josh and Owen here just start with very
high hips, meaning [music] they're not
able to get their hips into a position
where the quads can contribute much. And
Johannes here is somewhere in between.
We do pull in at least just a bit, but
we're not pulling in all the way. There
isn't enough tension or enough of a
push. So,
how do we fix it?
It's not as simple as just sit your hips
lower. We have to learn how to build
[music] tension before we start the
lift. In order to find tension,
find your appropriate position, and use
your quads properly in the deadlift, I
like to do this quick little checklist
when I set up for the pull. Number one,
heels, hips, and hamstrings. [music]
Push your weight way back on your heels
until you find tension in your hips and
hamstrings.
Number two, lats. Pull your arms long
and tighten your lats and resist the
weight of the bar with your upper back.
Number three, find your quads. Keeping
all of that other tension, literally use
the weight of the bar to pull your hips
down until we find pressure through the
whole foot and you feel your quads light
up. Once you've got that tension, when
you're starting the lift, be patient.
Fixing this issue is going to make your
deadlift feel a little bit harder off
the floor. That's a good thing, though.
If you're not used to this position,
your body will probably still try to
kick your hips up and force you to stiff
leg it. Making big adjustments to your
technique like this can be pretty
tricky. That's why we put so much
emphasis on exactly that in the Calgary
Barbell Training app. We do weekly video
check-ins to help our lifters refine
their technique so they're more
efficient and they get stronger faster.
If you prefer to roll the dice and
[music] potentially be selected for me
to look at in one of these videos, we
pull a few submissions from our inbox
each month and you could submit your
videos at calgarybarbell.com. And if
your deadlift looks like one of those
deadlifts from the videos at the start,
well, make sure that you're finding
tension before you start the lift.
That's going to help you fix your
position. It's going to allow you to use
your quads and to push, not pull, your
deadlift. If you can fix that, you're
going to feel a lot better
real fast.